delegating a high priority task to a  person who only delivers a bare minimum  style of work ethic otherwise will  probably result in the task not getting  done the foundation tried to snuff out  scp-682 with the help of scp-2599  formerly known as xena cho a woman of  korean descent who will carry out any  order you give her but only around  halfway that's why the foundation  ordered her to attack 682 until it was  200 dead so even if she only did her  task by halves it would still be one  hundred percent dead by all accounts she  was actually doing a pretty solid job  horrifically mutilating the creature to  the point of near death when it suddenly  yelled kill me you sacrifice do it and  that order seemingly confused her seeing  as only going halfway on killing the  creature was something she'd already  done she remained motionless in the test  chamber until she was physically removed  and later attempts to use her in 682's  termination were fruitless